[Music]
what you're about to watch in this room
is a strange mortal combat between a man
himself good day residents of the
internet and welcome back to the show
that today
fits two for boating anthologies against
each other
one is primarily in black and white the
other in glorious technicolor
and i want to live in neither because
it's twilight zone versus black mirror
the og show from the genius mind of rod
serling is going up against stiff
competition with the modern look at
ourselves
and what we could or already have become
it's the ultimate deconstruction of two
dystopian delights that stand the test
of time
a match-up that could only happen in the
twilight zone
you've just crossed over into the
twilight zone
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one tomato meter slash audience
score
round two iconic moments round three
cultural relevance and then we'll toss a
wild card round into the mix to help
settle the score
and since this is the internet and it
lives on forever if any of those pig
doctors from the eye of the beholder
episode are watching
this is what beauty used to look like
all humans
aiming for this ask any of your swine
brethren
this is what hansen is got it it's
settled
okay now we can start who starts
two stars wasn't a meaningful encounter
they pick the most dangerous enemy they
can find
and it's themselves round one tomato
meter slash audience score
back when the twilight zone began rotten
tomatoes were just old veggies you'd
bring to a comedy show
critical gauges have certainly evolved
since 1959
but so has the twilight zone after its
initial run through 1964
the show took a long breather it was
then revived as a movie in 1983
and then a new series run through the
later part of the 1980s it went dormant
again
then returned on upn for one season in
2002
like pennywise the clown it would then
depart only to return
years later in its current iteration on
cbs
with jordan peele stepping into the rod
sterling curator role
today however she will have no choice
but to revisit history again
and again peel has certainly turned the
zone back into a fresh property
after the ill-fated movie and upn run
both earned rotten scores on the tomato
meter
but the show has yet to return to peak
form in the 1960s
the original rod sterling era has an
average tomato meter score of 82 percent
and weighing it down is its only rotten
season during that time
season four at 57 percent all told
the twilight zone carries an average of
64
not bad for a concept that has spanned
half a century and is still going strong
but what happens when the zone glances
into the mirror
black mirror debuted overseas in 2011
and now
has five seasons worth of technological
tom foolery
brought to us by showrunners charlie
brooker and annabelle jones
black mirror has an impressive overall
average of 83 percent on the tomato
meter
that's even more striking when you
consider that the most recent season is
by far the lowest with a still fresh
67 percent season one set the high
market 98 percent
and its last three seasons on netflix
average 79 percent
for funsies that revolutionary snatch
project
that was at 72 percent sounds awesome
i see a trend critics love these shows
when they debut they're new they're
different they're creative
and then it gets tougher and tougher to
match the original gut punch
as the shows carry on is that how
audiences feel too
the average audience score for black
mirror is 81
and that once again handily defeats the
twilight zone's barely fresh average of
63 percent
and oddly enough it's the jordan peel
iteration of twilight zone that's
weighing it down the most at a rotten 39
percent
balancing that out is the original rod
sterling run which tops anything else in
twilight zone or black mirror
at 96 percent you see kids since the
1960s art has been all
downhill we had zoned we had the beatles
who were heavily influenced by the
monkeys
that should actually be an episode of
twilight zone
you are obsolete as to where it's with
speaking of black mirror that show also
is experiencing
its audience score a low point with its
most recent season
season five is being a party pooper at
45
maybe the quality is dipped or maybe
2020 feels like one long episode
and we don't have the appetite these
shows are many things but
uplifting ain't necessarily one of them
may i suggest
golden girls or mama's family instead
better late than blanched pregnant
the twilight zone gets major points in
this and every round for inspiring tons
of artistic endeavors
including black mirror but in this round
it's not just about how you start
it's how you finish and middle
because of that black mirror squeaks by
with a win and takes a surprising
one-nothing lead over twilight zone
jesus round two iconic moments
and now is where black mirror could
shock the world in just five short
seasons the show has managed to carve
out its own unique spot
in the cultural zeitgeist a word i'm 70
i just utilized accurately
it's impressive enough that black mirror
managed to separate itself from being
labeled just another twilight zone
imitation
all the iconic moments it's already
provided us that's just icing on the
cake
a cake that probably tastes like
licorice i'm betting the most obvious
example would be the moment that
surprised the world
and dominated social media in
bandersnatch
an interactive movie revolution that
allowed the viewer to make decisions
and suffer consequences it was almost
like a choose your own adventure novel
maybe a little too close it caused a
lawsuit by
chooseco who owns those book rights and
i dare anyone to prove that they had
heard of chooseco
prior to right now but that episode also
snagged two prime time emmys and for
once gave viewers a positive outlook on
a future where
we get to interact with our favorite tv
shows in a whole new way
it was ahead of its time in as much as
time exists
that's a considerable left turn from the
norm that is black mirror
usually tech either falls into our hands
or is already in existence
and it's that obsession that leads to
our downfall take the very first episode
the national anthem
i can't fully express the places to
which this episode takes our imagination
but needless to say it was the perfect
opening salvo for the episodes to follow
and if it's bleak you won
how about that one with jon hamm that
got everyone talking
and then crying and then sign and then
basically giving up
what's it called the christmas episode
perfect
we're all in a never-ending cycle
trapped inside our minds
when one thinks of specific moments that
unfolded in the show you could look at
striking vipers one of the comparatively
happier episodes
watching gamers fully immerse inside a
video game
and then to see where that action goes
it's groundbreaking
or when we realize just how far humans
are willing to go to avoid embarrassment
and worse in shut up and dance webcams
and video games weren't a thing yet when
rod sterling kicked off the twilight
zone
and his imagination didn't need them his
initial shepherding of that show gave us
arguably as many iconic moments
as any other program in history i'm even
talking to you monday night football
monsters are due on maple street mirror
image and where
is everybody are all landmark episodes
in tv history
as is big tall wish in large part due to
the fact that it was unfortunately rare
to have a black lead of a show in the
early 1960s
as a fan of the program myself i would
instantly refer someone to william
shatner's
slow unraveling in terror at twenty
thousand feet there's a man
on the wing there's someone on the way
or a patient waking up to a very
different looking doctor in eye of the
beholder
twilight zone is at its best in those
moments when the lead character
first starts to sense something is amiss
witness anne francis in the after hours
realizing that she is in fact a
mannequin
or even at the very end of time enough
at last as burchest meredith
has one accident that leads to a
lifetime of mental torture
more recent incarnations of twilight
zone haven't born as much memorable
fruit
but there were a few moments in the
1980s guest stars like bruce willis
would show up
and in his episode shatter day he was
directed by
horror master wes craven i'd also point
you towards the nightcrawlers episode
and it's ultra violent conclusion from
the exorcist and french connection
director
william friedkin twilight's zone has
always attracted a-list
talent so when jordan peele agreed to
take the reins for a
new generation it was no surprise
already his takes have given us some
clever updates on twilight's own
originals
the comedian and not just because one's
talking right now
and the new and improved tear at 30 000
feet
the replay episode had a darker
groundhog day vibe as does the topher
grace starring try
try episode the best one yet in my not
humble at all opinion would be blurry
man starring zazzy beats
you know what i think we can beat this
and for giggles i do have to point out
that the 2002 reboot
at least had forest whitaker host and
there was an episode where catherine
heigl went back in time to kill baby
hitler
i'm pretty sure even the stuffy suits at
the tec in the 1994 classic time cop
would have approved that mission
if heigl wants to do it sure send
catherine heigl
i like 27 dresses
the shared dna of these shows is that
beautifully twisted reveal
where we the audience are rewarded for
our suspicion
and are allowed in on the plot in black
mirrors
san junipero we're hanging on before we
realize
oh that ah and in twilight zones aliens
it's the very end when we get conked on
the head with wait
were the these quotes weren't even
me playing coy with you and not giving
away spoilers that was genuinely
word for word my reaction when the shows
gave us the full monty
can i use that catchphrase in this
context
um black mirror is off to a hot start
but it's going up against over 60 years
of twilight zone memorable moments
and that's just me talking about the rod
sterling era it was like 60 years worth
of greatness
twilight zone takes round two and we're
all deadlocked at one a piece
no logic no reason no explanation just a
prolonged nightmare
round three cultural relevance we're all
tied up but the twilight zone starts
round three with dynamite field position
if it's cultural relevance the customer
wants we don't have to go run to the
back and check the stock room
we have decades upon decades of
greatness that has influenced
pretty much every other show ever in
some fashion
so why do i even bother talking out
around three is it because i get
paid by the word
black mirror does actually have a shot
in this round and not just because the
show name itself is constantly used to
describe
anything weird that happens in our lives
worldwide pandemic
black mirror iphone facetime someone all
by itself
that's black mirror the mcflurry machine
is always broke when i roll up to mickey
d's
that is a recurring series of black
mirror episodes and i want it to stop
but it also resonates with the culture
because it shows us where humanity
society and technology is going if the
twilight zone is an
alternate universe showcase of basic
carnal human instincts
black mirror reveals to us where those
instincts are going to be taking us
black mirror head writer charlie brooker
has even pinned down current society
without writing an episode
he was recently quoted as saying he
doesn't want to write season 6 right now
because the world is too bleak
but it's also a better world for having
a show in it an article in the
independent recently noted that
entertainment options from the invisible
man to i am mother to wounds and sorry
to bother you
have all been influenced by black mirror
and the show is frighteningly accurate
when it comes to predicting
how social media can influence our world
the national anthem and hate it in the
nation are both harbingers of how apps
like twitter can be used for good or
evil
and word is that china is developing a
networking system that is eerily similar
to one used in the nosedive episode
heck waldo is an episode where a cartoon
character gets elected president
and fascism is allowed to rule the day
no one takes you seriously that's why no
one votes
and again shut up and dance i can know
nothing in that episode but i do enjoy
the aerosmith song
of the same name brooker has claimed a
number of eclectic influences on his own
work
with movies like airplane and evil dead
as well as directors like paul verhoven
making the list
but one just needs to watch a few
minutes of any black mirror season to
see
how heavily influenced it was by the
granddaddy of them all
suspended in time and space for a moment
zone's cultural resonance
has never been stronger stemming from
creator rod serling's own experiences
with
ptsd following his service in world war
ii
writing stories like the ones found in
his show would prove to be a healing
outlet
and through his work in the realm of
science fiction he was able to inject
societal commentary that normally
wouldn't pass the censors of his day
racism and struggles for equality were a
hallmark of the 1960s
but rarely made it into tv shows
sterling found that by wrapping up his
stories under the label of fantasy and
including aliens and the occasional
monster
he could get his message across the
airwaves right under the ad agency's
unsuspecting nostrils
the purpose the point of a dramatic show
which is used as a vehicle of social
criticism
is to involve an audience to show them
where in their guilt lies or at least
indeed their association
if you want to just consider the horror
genre watch an episode
like mirror image and see the evidence
that it inspired flicks like psycho and
eventually
us number 12 looks just like you is a
precursor to the stepford wives and the
trade-ins would help usher in the
concept
of get out the show had a huge impact on
so many of the artists we admire
today from directors like tim burton and
end night shyamalan
to writers like stephen king and gene
roddenberry the series has been listed
as the seventh greatest show of
all time by rolling stone and placed
fifth
on tv guide's list of the best dramas
ever
and in 1997 tv guide listed to serve man
at number 11 and it's a good life at
number 31
in their best episodes in tv history
rankings
and while the legacy of the twilight
zone film is much darker as a wrongful
death case was brought on director
john landis as a result of two actors
dying in an onset accident
landis was ultimately acquitted but that
horrific day
changed movie set safety practices
forevermore
jordan peele and his love for zone are
working to continue the legacy
but regardless if he's successful or not
one simply cannot overestimate the
breadth of twilight zone's impact
don't believe me go watch any treehouse
of horror simpsons episode
are you back okay black mirror has a
handle on technology and where it's
taking us
but for now it's twilight zone with the
most cultural influence
of just about any show ever made it wins
the round and goes up two to one
i mean you shouldn't say such things as
nonsense
and ridiculous
well that's the way it goes and now it's
time for the wild card round
the creators yes in the wild card round
we're going to pit the show's creators
against each other
and if anyone could have seen that
coming it's probably the twilight zone
or black mirror creators themselves
rod sterling with his knowing grin and
smoldering cigarette versus charlie
brooker the wonder kind who
if tv doesn't work out can definitely
fall back as an apple store genius
rod sterling gets huge points not just
for fighting for our country in world
war
ii but using his experiences and trauma
as fuel for a creative outlet that would
be ahead of his time
years from now we'll still marvel at how
much sterling got right about humanity
and our most intimate biases but by then
waas would be like hey i'm addicted to
this new app and that feels like a black
mirror episode
in addition to being a brilliant
television writer brooker is also an
accomplished cartoonist
satirist and yes even critic is he
certified on the tomato i'll
i'll look into that get back to you his
comedy influences being from britain
we're naturally monty python and the way
he can inject
subtle humor into even the bleakest
black mirror episode
is impressive even if the show
ultimately leaves us feeling like our
future is doomed
the amount of variety with which he can
get us to that conclusion
is astounding in episodes like play test
it's video games
in the history of you it's a fancy
contact lens and in uss
callister it's just unabashed love for
star trek
with rod sterling a hopeful ending was a
little bit less of a pipe dream
but more often than not we saw the light
at the end of the tunnel
just before a massive curveball blew our
minds
in to serve man the aliens are actually
eating people
nothing in the dark is another classic
and not just because a super young
robert redford was in it
did rod serling know back then that bob
redford would go on to be a secret
member of hydra
am i really so bad the leg up that rod
sterling will always have
is his vintage appearances in each
episode
later paid homage by forrest whitaker
and jordan peele
sirling's handsome yet singularly unique
look
gave way to a voice that could both
comfort and unsettle us in the same
sentence
whatever was about to happen or no
matter the nutty event we just witnessed
sterling was always there to offer
appropriate context
and when you look back on those it's
also clear he was reiterating to the
audience that the show we just watched
wasn't just about extraterrestrials or
the afterlife or ventriloquist dummies
it was about us any state any entity any
ideology that fails to recognize the
worth the dignity the rights of man
that state is obsolete a case to be
filed under m for mankind
brooker lets his tech wizardry do the
talking for him most of the time but
it's no less effective
one could conceivably form a spin-off
show just based on the practical
appliance of his imagination
you're telling me you wouldn't watch a
youtube show about how to put your dead
partner into a robot
come on you've spent hours watching
grown adults unbox
toys but you're telling me you wouldn't
check out soldiers using the neural
implant
mass get real y'all brooker is a
visionary and i can't wait to see where
the rest of his career takes him
and us but the winner of the wild card
round is the guy
who came into everyone's living room via
tv set once a week
in the 1960s america trusted ed sullivan
to tell the kids what's going on in rock
and roll
and also trusted rod serling to deliver
messages about ourselves
wrapped in a palatable shell of finely
crafted horror sci-fi
ron sterling gets the point and his baby
goes up three to one
i think it's very possible to perform a
function
of providing adult meaningful exciting
challenging drama
without dealing in controversy
necessarily it was going to be an uphill
climb for black mirror today
which is not to say don't watch it in
fact i think it's one of the best shows
on tv
and its shadow looms large over the
current version of the twilight
zone but for all the zones that have
ever existed in history
this isn't just a nostalgia win it's an
earned victory that reminds us all what
the 1960s were really about
societal change through politics laws
music and storytelling
for that we all owe rod sterling a huge
debt of gratitude
and i'm about to pay him respect right
now
[Music]
submitted for your approval a voting
machine the likes of which will
determine the winner between two
television programs although your
narrator appears to be in control
the reality is he is trapped in a
dimension from which he cannot escape
awaiting the right comment that may set
him free
or is he already free fate is what we
make of it
both in your world and here
in the twilight zone
[Music]
you